all right I've got scissors and a pizza
cutter because I didn't know where the
craft knife was anyways let's open the
biggest model I have ever gotten by a
long shot
this beauty is seven and a half of kgs
which in pounds or whatever the other
people measuring is a magic number that
I don't understand
point is it's massive I played horizon
zero dawn recently it's a world with is
you know giant dinosaurs that are robots
and bows and arrows and beautiful
stunning game I loved it so much and I
wanted to you know save up and get
something really cool something you know
I haven't bought a model in mages and I
wanted to get something to kind of show
my love for the series in a weird way I
don't know but this is the Tyrannosaurus
Rex robot basically if you don't know
the game and let's open it up
I can just hear the earth choking on
this plastic I am so sorry
this is now free of its cage and it's
called a thunder door beautiful name and
seriously if you haven't played the game
and you have a ps4 that I think that's
coming to PC soon which is awesome get
it it's not only got a great story it's
got a great world it's got a cool
character the rest of them aren't that
interesting but the main characters
pretty cool she's funny and she's she's
awesome
which is great love it also the comet is
just brilliant so many games are so
focused on the ability to engage quickly
and you know would be really know the
numbers behind the weapons and the armor
and stuff that's not very accessible to
people who aren't super into combat
stuff so the game is largely you know
designed around dodging sitting traps
and more defensive maneuvers which is a
really different style of gameplay that
really jived with me I loved you know
you set up a whole row of traps and then
you lure enemies into it that's a big
part of my playstyle and it was just it
was just great and funnily enough
despite these guys being some of the
biggest enemies that you find they're
not actually the most powerful or
dangerous because you know they're kind
of big lumbering things anyways let's
get this box open not a box
and oh I don't I like I love the artwork
here like I might even just like take
that and put that on my wall that'd do
you - I hope I didn't damage it this is
what the Thunder door looks like it's
like just tilt it up a bit
oh my gosh we could even like more art
so that's what it looks like even more
you can you can see that's a boy down
there she's she's a main character she's
cool
uses a bow so it's bow driven combat
which is awesome Bart's encased and
polystyrene great
[Music]
you ready
Wow
what is this let's find out I thought I
was gonna have to do some assembly but I
only not versus material of some kind in
there oh oh I forgot this completely ha
ha ha
this is the map of the world that you
know you you are a part of looks like
this so this is the world you start it
you know you you start around here
and then you go out around here go ever
yeah these are kind of major plot points
and you're going you're all your massive
adventure I completely forgot this was
even part of the pack that's awesome I'm
so happy with that I'm gonna put that up
on my wall but I'll probably frame it
then what's this other thing oh these
are just some nice bits of art so this
is concept art really nice but the
pieces of card beautiful well so that's
like a ton ink which is basically one
starred kind of like a giraffe and they
store a huge amount of like data and
information scanning the landscape so
turns out that there are actually little
extra bits to your means to attach which
is super cool
[Music]
because I was like I don't know it looks
off for her thing and I was right so
this is the tail which I'll put on
that's looking more like it
and this this is an item from the story
called of focus and basically it's kind
of like a communication device and
Internet device that allows you to hit
her to get access to kind of a
technological network across the game
you put it if I can sneak under here
like they're against against your uh
against your your your forehead
your temple yeah your temple so doesn't
it doesn't it doesn't go on here but
there you go
this is the Thunder jaw and if seeing
this doesn't make you want to play the
game than I dental what will so yeah
anyways cheers for unpacking this with
me this has been amazing I love this
thing so much I like to find space to
put it now anyways I'll see you guys in
the future and stay nerdy have a good
one